get ready for the greatest honest
trailer competition of all time Michael
Keaton's Batman versus Christopher
Reeves Superman two honest trailers one
epic showdown stay tuned to the end of
the trailer to see how you can determine
the winner now get ready for Batman
before christopher nolan's saved bad man
from nipples raves and ice puns so Tim
Burton had to save him from this you
know your neosaurus as well Robin peanut
butter sandwiches it is pulling kriti
reboot quick to the reboot mobile Tim
Burton's Batman gear up for a movie that
took the bad part of Batman
pretty literally as one man wages a war
against crime in an awesome-looking bat
suit and a severely limited range of
motion
wow that is stiff can even hearing that
thing say what you want about Adam West
at least he was able to move
witness one of the best superhero
castings of all time in Michael Keaton a
man so perfect for the role his eyebrows
are shaped like the logo
he's a reclusive billionaire dressed
like your 10th grade English teacher
who's so unstable
come on let's get it actually feels
plausible he would pretend to be a bad
and beat up poor people I think your
friend Wang has really screwed up but
the bad man can only be defined by his
Joker and Jack Nicholson is the
definitive Joker except for Heath Ledger
or if you're a Mark Hamill guy and Leno
looks kind of rad in Suicide Squad you
know now that I think about it Nicholson
is kind of just doing the Cesar Romero
impression you know what let's back this
up but the bad man can only be defined
by his Joker and Jack Nicholson is one
of them watch as Jack Nicholson place
himself
Jack Jack until an accident transforms
him into a slightly creepier version of
himself who laughed so much he literally
couldn't laugh anymore if he tried
I think he ran out of laughing gas
if you thought Batman had a rule against
killing you were wrong as this version
of the character ditches beating up
criminals and ops were straight-up
murder
fans are ticked off he's got a gun in
the new trailer this Batman's a serial
killer
I'm not going to kill you now it
probably is so Sudha for the blockbuster
that seamlessly blended dark and gritty
with can that not only created the look
feel and music that would define Batman
for years to come
I'm Batman I'm Batman but set the pace
for every comic book movie to follow
from trailer hi
the Batman trailer it may be better than
the movie that follows up to
merchandising from billboards to
lunchboxes the frisbees to angry fanboy
backlash before the movie is even
released there was a controversy when
actor Michael Keaton was cast to play
Batman in the comic is fixed but you can
in fact now that I think about it this
movie checked every box and break the
internet bingo before there was even an
internet that's a year changed the
origin a controversial lead killed the
heroes main villain completely change
the costume oh man
I'm on a hot streak cast a black guy to
play a white guy hey I got angry
internet nerd bingo do I win anything
starring battle juice here's Joker
batgirls uncle you either die a hero or
live long enough to be recast in the
sequel Jack Nicholson's buddy that
Nicholson insisted be in the movie or he
wouldn't do it and Vicki Vale screaming
enough already
Batman Burton's okay I've been trying to
figure out what Joker says here for 26
years
I'm of a mind make some Mookie I have a
mind makes a movie I'm of a mind make
some Mookie hide on mines make the moola
ah this is gonna bug me forever you've
seen the Dark Knight take down the Joker
now click on the box above to see
Superman take on Lex Luthor in this epic
competition between two honest trailers
are you team Superman or team Batman
we'll determine a winner based on the
only thing that really matters fuse if
the Caped Crusader gets more views we'll
make an honest trailer for Batman Begins
if the Man of Steel dominates we'll do
one for Superman Returns so click on the
box above to see the honest trailer for
Superman 78 and be sure to watch and
share because the fate of Batman and
Superman are in your hands give me more
than one slice of banana bread or I will
lose all control one batch to batch
penny and time hey everyone stop the
Planet of the Apes I want to get off
fire the Manatee cannon Batman hates
Superman because he stole his guacamole
have you ever danced with the devil in
the pale moonlight